pep's collègues et conférencière
rose-marie charest est avec nous pour
répondre à vos questions d'ordre
psychologique
donc vous pouvez toujours nous les faire
parvenir sur nos pages facebook rdi
matin ou par courriel rdi matin week-end
arobas radio canada.ca rose-marie
charest bonjour ou alors vu ce sont des
questions d'ordre psychologique je garde
la confidentialité
le nom des gens qui nous ont écrit mais
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que c'est
lent voire ce qui est ressort le plus le
beaucoup beaucoup de questions
concernant l'anxiété depuis le début de
la crise
est-ce que premièrement là pour nous
calmer un peu vous avez quelque chose à
nous dire à ce sujet là à écouter la
première chose c'est que d'être anxieux
actuellement c'est normal parce qu'on
est face à une situation qui est anormal
donc ça exige beaucoup d'adaptations
notre part notre psyché effet pour
pouvoir prévoir ce qui va arriver dans
tout l'inconnu avec augmente l'intensité
tout fait que ce soit imprévisible et
surtout fait qu'on n'ait pas contrôle
sur la situation
donc la première chose nos sites web
bienveillant envers soi même ne pas s'en
faire 200 faire elle bienveillant envers
des autres qui n'ont pas nécessairement
non plus exactement l'attitude
souhaitable les bons comportements parce
que l'anxiété ça fait pas toujours
sortir le meilleur de nous mêmes
donc ça c'est une première chose à faire
accepter que pour le moment c'est comme
ça mais l'anxiété va diminuer we have
been oui oui parce que la nouveauté de
l'annoncer tout ça ça fait augmenter
puis par l'ac milan
écoutez quand on dit on s'habitue à tout
le principe d'habituation qui va faire
en sorte que sauf ceux qui vont être
directement touché où l'eau il va avoir
un stress supplémentaire dans cette rue
proche de libéraliser maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire on peut on et
regardons les différentes composantes de
soi qu'à l'ordinaire or qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire pour se détendre physiquement
si vous sentez une tension musculaire
m'avoir
car relâcher la vous aime ça vous avez
de contrôle là dessus si vous vous
apercevez que vous respirez rapidement
premier temps de respirer lentement ça
c'est une chose que vous pouvez faire
pour vous même allez faire une marche
qui peuvent encore ceux qui s'entraînent
et continuez de vous entraîner il ya
tellement moyens pour s'entraîner à
distance il ya toutes sortes de
programmes qui ont été faites vous
plaisir
c'est pas parce que la situation est
difficile qu'on doit la vivre
constamment de manière difficile pour
les ouïghours dans nos journées en
j'imagine la les activités peut-être
auquel on s'adonnait pas nécessairement
avant ou permettre des choses aux
enfants qui normalement était peut-être
interdite ou moins permis
absolument autant on sait que d'avoir un
horaire une routine ça va rassurer les
enfants
d'ailleurs ça nous rassure aussi j'en
recommande une aussi pour les études une
certaine routine même routine réaliste
compte tenu de la réalité actuelle est
effectivement de donner un peu plus de
marge de manoeuvre pour nos principes
qui était important pour tout ce que tu
entends des cas les enfants et les
adolescents ont besoin d'être en contact
avec leur langue ils voyaient leurs amis
peuvent plus d'ivoire pour leur
permettre un peu plus de les voir de
façon virtuelle apprendre à jouer à
avoir du plaisir découvrir des nouveaux
je savais à partir du moment où on a
fait ce sur quoi on avait du contrôle on
s'est protégé on a protégé les autres on
s'est informé raisonnablement mais pas
quinze heures par jour on s'est informé
de source sûre on a assuré un certain
bien-être au quotidien
le reste on peut dire là je prends une
heure de vacances de tout chaud dans la
journée je m'amuse je fais quelque chose
qui me fait plaisir et d'afflux j'ai des
questions d'enseignants a aussi amélioré
parce que ce qu'on sait c'est que les
enseignants à partir de demain sont
invités par québec à appeler leurs
élèves à prendre contact avec eux que ce
soit par le téléphone ou de façon
virtuelle
il ya une dame qui écrit bonjour en fait
seul un homme je suis enseignant au
primaire
je demande qu'on
nous devrons accueillir nos élèves lors
d'un éventuel retour en classe mais
surtout comment les aborder et les
rassurer maintenant pendant la crise bon
l'éventuel retour en classe cette
question là vous permet d'aborder un
autre thème kg et l'importance de rester
centré dans le moment présent
on peut pas actuellement au jury tout ce
qui va se passer d'un prochainement
parce qu'on ne peut pas l'information
donc pour lui vendre mais pour la
question est très très pertinents ce com
en garde un bon contact avec vous ses
lèvres
n'oublions pas la force de l'image d'un
enseignant dans la vie d'un enfant
si vous pensez peut-être sept enfants la
vie dans une famille que de la
difficulté actuellement à se calmer donc
la première chose à faire pour vous
c'est d'essayer de vous détendre le plus
possible avant de faire sa peine de
reconnaître l'importance de cet enfant
là dans votre plage veut le reconnaître
l'importance de ce qu'il a brand qui
écrit ce que comme un être humain dit en
train d'apprendre
actuellement parce qu'on était en train
d'apprendre quelque chose de quand même
important organisé notre vie quand tu y
arrives un élément extérieur qu'on avait
pour choisi il y aura six ans avant et
après sa prise lakovic 19